dans l'univers de l'espionnage
il y un agent dont les services secrets
eux mêmes préfèrent ignorer l'existence
julienc juge jeudi voire des gaz
cela dit j'ai tout mon temps bientôt on
dit que la chorale d'orsan est
incroyable c'est le plat que
j'affectionne le plus au monde
soyez prêt à entrer en cela me rappelle
le gadget que le service mettait à notre
disposition
aux yeux du profane stylo et nous mais
j'ai cliqué voyante au service secret de
sa majesté
j'espère que tout est aux normes une
liche en disant en ordre je crois
monsieur que vous êtes en dessous de la
réalité
vous êtes ici dans la zone la plus
sécurisée de toute la grande-bretagne
données english